why diversity
why women on board
because all research and economic
studies show
that companies that embrace diversity
are more successful
and this is true in business and
politics and in society as a whole
and still
too often especially when looking at top
positions
we hear men say that it is not possible
to find women with the right profile
well
if you are seriously looking for them
you will find them
it has been 10 years since the
commission proposed to set a target of
40 for women on boards of publicly
listed european firms
for 10 years our efforts to put in place
a european legislation
have been blocked
10 years where voluntary measures have
not brought the change we need
the glass ceiling remains firm in place
at the top of european companies
if we look beyond boards
at the top leadership positions
just seven percent of the largest
european companies are led by a woman
boards are one thing
it is the knock-on effect that matters
as more diverse boards hire more diverse
ceos who
in turn hire more divers managers
that's what counts
legislation works
i will push as president of the
commission to ensure
that our proposal on women on boards
becomes european union law